ça va chuter rappelle mes origines en
fait c'est quoi tes lauriers parce que
j'ai grandi à strasbourg mais juste à
côté d'un zoo municipal
[Rires]
c'est loin d'arriver quand même à faire
de telles audiences avec des prises
c'est tout ça marche ça
je suis désolé ça marche c'est quel
animal ça ça vous passez le guépard qui
monte aux arbres comment vous le savez
pas ce que le jaguar court plus vite que
le guépard non mais ce que c'est un
complice avec sa
brosse exergue est passé légèrement
tacheté comme ça non parce que
normalement alors je vous dis rassure
non non pas du tout c'est pas la couleur
c'est les tâches du guépard ou du
léopard nom d'une opa qui sont coupées
au bout elles sont coupées en deux oui
elles sont pas complètement elle se
soigne pas complètement je crois je ne
devrais pas d'arnèke kg de métaux
maintenant herbes hachées pam est tombé
je voudrais les tâches puisque jean
travailleurs
allez
c'est dur ça l'est mais ça me connaît il
faut pas que la tenue les cheveux à quel
moment tu nous dis quelque chose
[Rires]
ça quel manuel macro annoncé sa
candidature
à quel moment tu va annoncer sa
candidature pour l'économie
ah ah
[Applaudissements]
déposer la candidature directement
ce niveau les trois dernières quittances
de loyer
une top baril
les quatre mois dernière fiche
d'imposition et bien sûr si tu préfère
aller sur mykonos ou sur paros
mathieu tu peux le cul tu peux recevoir
un ami ton petit coeur et puis après tu
vois ton petit
muret très bien oui mais vous savez que
c'est une grande décision babolat voilà
alors mais ça pas vraiment un lien mais
j'ai lu un article sur doctissimo qui
m'a convaincu de devenir non binaire et
non genre est donc faux pas ne plus
appeler monsieur ni madame fable et
mathieu
explique mathieu
non c'est vrai que vous êtes vous n'êtes
ni pour vous je me considérais comme mon
genre et tient réunion jean reinhardt
est indéfini bien jusqu'où on a fait un
petit pas quand même des
gars
sympa oui il va très bien fait mon job
sera ouais bon binaire
combiné à fait ordinaire c'est
mobilières comme le pays est là c'est à
dire y est je suis ni un garçon d'une
fille est d'accord la crise aidant
jarret et non binaire aussi c'est bien
c'est pareil à la bon d'accord mais vous
êtes quoi vous non genre et non
[Applaudissements]
sequana ordinaire c'est non c'est non
j'aurais peut-être c'est comme dans
binaire d'accord mais vous avez vous
compris dans les deux mots et surtout
ils n'ont hétéro et non aux mots il est
juste amoureux d'amour et je suis une
femme
une femme avec des couilles
[Applaudissements]
il faut les respecter ce que vous avez
dit hier que sur la plage de mykonos et
coquillages et que casser oui oui je
crois qu'il va juste pour les côtiers
je pense que ça suffira et ouais vous
plaisir épanouie en tout cas
vous avez quelque chose à nous dire non
mais l'autre jour tu avais l'air bien
genre et quant à fermer la porte de la
loge et que j'étais tout seul dedans
[Applaudissements]
et que tu m'as dit est ce qu'on dit que
maintenant daniel comme
sur ce je rappelle mon snap le chiffre
de boulbi elle m'a
dit
ça m'a dit est ce que tu es intéressé
par un plan semblable à dans les loges
gyrotrac à zéro tracas durable j'ai par
email à moi
[Applaudissements]
vous avez dit noah guillaume s'il savait
aller avec quelqu'un d'autre
bah bien sûr s'il y avait la fine bouche
a gagné
12 chaque daniel et je vous cache pas
que
marseille avait dit à l'est de la butte
abandonné ou fermé
sa ferme au dow
[Rires]
rien on n'était pas le gel douche que
j'ai senti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]